>> Dana: THURSDAYS ARE GREAT
DAYS.
HARRIS FAULKNER IS UP NEXT.
>> Harris: THE WHITE HOUSE IS
GETTING CALLED OUT ON SHOCKING
ALLEGATIONS OF CHILD SEX ABUSE
AT A MIGRANT CENTER INIGATION.
I’M HARRIS FAULKNER AND YOU ARE
IN THE "THE FAULKNER FOCUS".
GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAYS THE WHITE
HOUSE HAS TO CLOSE A SAN
ANTONIO FACILITY.
ABBOTT SAYS HE IS RECEIVING
TIPS THAT MIGRANT CHILDREN WERE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED THERE AND
INSUFFICIENT FOOD AMID OTHER
ALLEGATIONS OF ABUSE.
GOVERNOR ABBOTT SAYS PRESIDENT
BIDEN’S POLICIES ARE FUELING
THIS HORROR.
>> THESE PROBLEMS ARE A
BYPRODUCT OF PRESIDENT BIDEN’S
OPEN BORDER POLICIES.
THIS FACILITY IS A HEALTH AND
SAFETY NIGHTMARE.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS NOW
PRESIDING OVER THE ABUSE OF
CHILDREN.
TO END THIS ABUSE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MUST IMMEDIATELY
SHUT DOWN THIS FACILITY.
>> Harris: THEN THERE IS THIS.
AN ARIZONA BORDER CHIEF HAS
RELEASED THE PHOTO SHOWING 130
MIGRANTS AT THE BORDER AS THE
SURGE SHOWS NO SIGN OF SLOWING
DOWN.
IN FOCUS NOW.
ARIZONA ATTORNEY GENERAL,
ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANK YOU FOR
BEING ON THE PROGRAM.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
HARRIS.
>> Harris: I WANT TO START OFF
WITH WHAT YOU NEED TO DO NEXT
IN THE STATE OF TEXAS BECAUSE
WHEN YOU HEAR THE GOVERNOR, YOU
TWO WORK IN CONCERT, I WOULD
IMAGINE, TOGETHER.
YOU ARE THE LEGAL ARM OF THAT.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE COMMUNICATED,
HOW IS IT BEING COMMUNICATED TO
THE WHITE HOUSE?
>> WELL, I THINK THE GOVERNOR
OF TEXAS HAS DONE A GREAT JOB.
I THINK THAT HE HAS TRIED TO DO
SOMETHING.
THERE IS A RUNNING JOKE WHEN
GOVERNOR ABBOTT DOES SOMETHING
SOME OF THE OTHER GOVERNORS
WILL SAY THE RIGHT THING A WEEK
LATER.
I CAN ONLY CONTROL WHAT I CAN
DO.
AS YOU KNOW I HAVE MULTIPLE
LAWSUITS RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE A HEARING TODAY IN
FEDERAL COURT TRYING TO
REINSTITUTE THE DEPORTATION
POLICY.
THERE IS 1.2 MILLION PEOPLE
HERE SCHEDULED FOR DEPORTATION.
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HALTED
THAT.
WE KNOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION GOT RID OF THE
PUBLIC CHARGE RULE SO PEOPLE
AREN’T GETTING CHILDCARE AND
MEDICARE AND OTHER PUBLIC
HEALTH BENEFITS THAT TAXPAYERS
ARE PAYING FOR.
I THINK IT IS IMPORTANT TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO THESE ISSUES.
WHAT IS HAPPENING ON THE BORDER
IS A CRISIS RIGHT NOW BUT IT IS
ABOUT TO BECOME A PREVENTABLE
TRAGEDY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SET IN MOTION
WITH ALL THE VARIOUS POLICIES.
THEY’VE ELIMINATED THE REMAIN
IN MEXICO POLICY SO THEY HAVE
ENCOURAGED PEOPLE TO COME HERE
AND INCENTIVIZED IT AND
DECRIMINALIZING IT AND WE KNOW
THERE ARE CRIMINAL GANG MEMBER
AND MIDDLE EASTERN TERRORISTS
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Harris: THERE ARE FACTS WITH
THAT NOW.
THIS IS NOT JUST A POINT OF
OPINION THAT SOMEONE THOUGHT
THEY COULD DEBATE AT ONE POINT
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
THERE ARE NUMBERS AND VIDEO AND
PICTURES.
SPEAKING OF WHICH NEW NUMBERS
FROM THE H.H.S. AND D.H.S. NOW,
ATTORNEY GENERAL, ARE SHOWING
AN EYE-POPPING 20,000 PLUS
CHILD MIGRANTS IN FEDERAL
CUSTODY.
NEARLY 19,000 UNACCOMPANIED
CHILDREN WERE ENCOUNTERED ON
THE BORDER IN JUST MARCH.
THAT’S A 100% INCREASE FROM
FEBRUARY.
AND THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS NOW REPORT THAT
172,000 PEOPLE IN TOTAL
ATTEMPTED TO CROSS THE BORDER
IN MARCH AND THAT’S A 71%
INCREASE FROM FEBRUARY.
MOST OF THEM SINGLE ADULTS.
TELL ME WHAT IS HAPPENING TO
LET THAT -- LET THOSE NUMBERS
INCREASE SO QUICKLY.
>> WELL, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS ESSENTIALLY
SIGNALED AN OPEN DOOR.
YOU MENTIONED THE POLITICS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE GOING ON.
I KEEP TELLING FOLKS THIS ISN’T
AN ISSUE OF RIGHT VERSUS LEFT.
IT’S AN ISSUE OF RIGHT VERSUS
WRONG.
IT MAY BE IN OUR FRONT YARD
TODAY BUT EVERYONE’S BACKYARD
TOMORROW.
YOU MENTIONED THE NUMBER OF
174,000 TO PUT IT IN CONTEXT.
THAT’S THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF
A CITY LIKE TEMPE THAT HOSTS
THE FIESTA BOWL EVERY YEAR.
THE SIZE OF SYRACUSE, BIGGER
THAN SYRACUSE, NEW YORK.
WE’RE SEEING THE SYSTEM
OVERWHELMED AND WE KNOW THAT
ALONG WITH PEOPLE THAT ARE ON
THE TERRORIST WATCH LIST THAT
HAVE COME IN I KNOW THERE ARE
FOLKS FROM OTHER MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE COME IN.
IT IS UNSUSTAINABLE AND THERE
WILL BE A TRAGEDY AT SOME POINT.
LOOK AT THE BASIC NUMBERS.
I KNOW IN A COUNTY A SHERIFF
HAS A DECLARATION IN THE
HEARING THAT MORE THAN 50% OF
THE PEOPLE THAT THEY HAVE IN
CUSTODY NOW ARE REPEATERS.
THEY’VE BEEN CHARGED WITH
ASSAULT AND ROBBERY, FELONY
DRUG CHARGES THAT ARE BEING
APPREHENDED.
SO IT’S NOT JUST FOLKS COMING
TRYING TO FIND WORK.
THERE ARE CRIMINALS AND
DANGEROUS PEOPLE COMING INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND THIS IS GOING
TO AFFECT US FOR GENERATIONS IF
WE DON’T STOP THIS RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: YOU KNOW, IT HAS
BEEN TWO WEEKS SINCE VICE
PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS WAS
TAPPED TO OVERSEE THE SITUATION
THAT’S HAPPENING AT THE BORDER.
BUT THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS YET
TO HOLD A BRIEFING OR PAY A
VISIT TO THE BORDER.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS GETTING
DEFENSIVE WHEN ASKED ABOUT
HARRIS’S OTHER RECENT TRIPS
INCLUDING A BAKERY IN CHICAGO
ON TUESDAY.
LET’S WATCH AND I’LL GET YOUR
RESPONSE.
>> THE VICE PRESIDENT WAS
VISITING CHICAGO TO TALK ABOUT
COVID AND THE IMPORTANCE OF
COMMUNITIES GETTING THE VACCINE
WHEN IT IS AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO THEM AND SO WHILE
SHE WAS THERE LIKE MANY
AMERICANS, SHE GOT A SNACK.
I THINK SHE IS ALLOWED TO DO
THAT.
>> Harris: BEFORE WE GO WITH
YOU, LET’S HEAR FROM YOU U.N.
AMBASSADOR NIKKI HALEY WHO
UNLEASHED ON THE VICE PRESIDENT.
>> KAMALA HARRIS APPARENTLY SHE
IS THE ONE IN CHARGE.
THIS IS THE SAME PERSON THAT
ENCOURAGED 7,000 MIGRANTS TO
COME TO AMERICA.
SHE REFERRED TO ICE AS THE
K.K.K.
SHE IS NOW IN CHARGE OF THIS.
SHE HAS BEEN MISSING IN ACTION
AND GOD HELP US IF SHE EVER
BECOMES PRESIDENT.
IF THIS IS HOW SHE HANDLES A
CRISIS, I MEAN, I JUST CAN’T
IMAGINE HOW SHE WOULD RUN OUR
COUNTRY.
>> Harris: ATTORNEY GENERAL,
YOUR REACTION.
>> I GUESS MARIE ANTOINETTE
WANTED TO EAT CAKE AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT WANTS A SNACK.
I HAVE INVITED THE VICE
PRESIDENT TO COME DOWN HERE.
SHE WAS A FORMER STATE A.G.
WHILE I WAS A.G.
WE’RE BOTH CHILDREN OF
IMIMMIGRANTS.
SHE BELIEVES VERY STRONGLY
TRYING TO PREVENT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WE KNOW THE CARTELS ARE
EXPORTING PEOPLE.
I INVITE ONCE AGAIN THE VICE
PRESIDENT TO COME DOWN HERE AND
MEET WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
MYSELF.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THIS AND TRY
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE INSTEAD
OF DOING WASHINGTON, D.C. DOES
EVERY TIME, WHICH IS KICK THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD.
WE CAN’T DO THAT.
>> Harris: WELL, WHAT YOU
POINTED OUT AS WE WERE GOING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN TEXAS
AND ARIZONA, THIS IS HAPPENING
ALONG THE BORDER.
SHE WAS IN CALIFORNIA WHERE
THERE WAS ACTUALLY A WALL.
AND THAT WOULD BE THE ARGUMENT
FOR THE WALL, I SUPPOSE, SINCE
SHE LIVED THERE AND CERTAINLY
DIDN’T TEAR IT DOWN.
NOW YOU GET TO SEE THE AREAS
MORE POROUS WITHOUT THAT
FENCELINE.
I WOULD IMAGINE YOU WANT TO SEE
THAT, YOU KNOW?
IF YOU WILL ADJUDICATE ANYTHING
ABOUT IT.
LET’S MOVE TO THIS.
SUSPECTED MS-13 GANG MEMBER WAS
ARRESTED IN CALIFORNIA AFTER
ILLEGALLY CROSSING THE BORDER
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THIS COMES AFTER TWO SUSPECTED
YEMENI TERRORISTS WERE
APPREHENDED IN THE BORDER IN
THE PAST FEW MONTHS.
YOU ALLUDED TO THAT.
HOUSE MINORITY LEADER MCCARTHY
REQUESTED A CLASSIFIED BRIEFING
FROM THE FEDS ON THE SECURITY
THREAT.
YOUR REACTION.
>> THIS IS A NATIONAL SECURITY
THREAT.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT PEOPLE THINK
ABOUT THE BORDER ISSUE,
EVERYONE NEEDS TO APPRECIATE
THIS ISN’T ABOUT BORDER
SECURITY, IT IS ABOUT NATIONAL
SECURITY.
THERE ARE PEOPLE LITERALLY ON
THE TERRORIST WATCH LIST TRYING
TO GET INTO THIS COUNTRY.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE GOTTEN INTO
THIS COUNTRY ON THE TERRORIST
WATCH LIST AND PEOPLE FROM
ASSORTED MIDDLE EASTERN
COUNTRIES APPREHENDED.
THE SHERIFF OF A COUNTY TOLD US
MORE THAN HALF THE PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN CHARGED WITH DANGEROUS
CRIMES.
YOU HAVE NOT ONLY THE TERRORIST
THREAT, YOU HAVE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WITH CRIMINALS RECORDS
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY RIGHT
NOW AND WE KNOW FROM WHAT’S
GOING ON AT THE BORDER
SOMETIMES YOU’LL GET A RUSH OF
MIGRANTS LIKE 100 PEOPLE,
BORDER PATROL HAS TO GO AND
APPREHEND THEM AND PROCESS THEM.
WHILE THEY’RE DOING IT THE
CARTELS ARE LITERALLY DRIVING
TRUCKS ACROSS THE BORDER WHERE
THERE IS NO WALL.
SO ONCE AGAIN JOE BIDEN HAS
CREATED THIS BY DECRIMINALIZING
AND INCENTIVIZING IT.
I KEEP THINKING ABOUT WHAT
WILLIAM -- JOE BIDEN CREATED
THIS PROBLEM.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM RIGHT NOW OR ELSE
SOMEONE WILL REALLY GET HURT
AND THERE WILL BE A TERRIBLE
TRAGEDY IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Harris: LOOK, WHEN THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF ARIZONA
INVITES YOU TO COME TO THE
BORDER IT IS NOT LIKE A LIGHT
AFTERNOON OUT FOR LUNCH.
I WANT TO KNOW WHEN SHE
RESPONDS OR HER TEAM RESPONDS
AND YOU GUYS GET READY TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN.
>> I WILL BUY HER A PASTRY IF
IT WILL ENCOURAGE HER TO COME